think you guys could respect a guy
um and follow his lead if you make more
money than him
um
no I don't mind like in terms of
finances it doesn't make a difference to
me yeah I wouldn't mind if my partner
made more money than me it's as long as
you talk to me with the same level as
respect because I'm still earning so
what if you were paying 80 of the bills
and you had to buy a house so let's say
you pay that don't mean yeah let's say
that's it I'm just taking it to the ex
like to the extreme you're paying 80 of
the bills and he says we're buying this
house
and you don't like it you hate it are
you gonna go with it no I thought you'd
have to convince me why we're buying it
you have to make logical sense I I
personally I think that's the the whole
point is that you're not submitting if
he has to convince you sure that's like
if it's your boss and he tells you to do
something you just do it right so it's I
mean I think when we're being honest
it's hard to submit to someone if they
don't make more money and I feel like a
man is meant to be if you're married a
provider we're not Sole Provider but the
provider and I don't feel like if you're
not earning more than me you could
provide for me enough like fully and if
we're buying a house together and I
don't like it I'm not gonna and I'm
providing basically more it's going to
be more my decision I think it'd be hard
for me to submit to someone who isn't
basically being able to lead me you're
gonna have to be able to lead me and if
you're not earning more than me it's
going to be harder for me to agree or
listen to you it might sound oh that's
not nice but that's how I feel I can't
listen to someone that
isn't earning more than me but why is
that the one I just feel like it's just
because of the way I've been raised if I
for example I use my dad he's always
earned he's always been a no he's always
been able to look after me and his
family so that's what I see my future
husband doing and if you're not earning
more than me maybe if it's a short
period of time you've you've lost money
or you're down but I couldn't marry
someone that earns less than me I just
couldn't because how I see the role of a
man in a household you're meant to be a
leader provider I just couldn't well I
don't understand sometimes there's a
come up so they might be low yeah
beginning would could you stick by
someone that has a good heart and be
with them through the come up
to be honest with you I thought maybe
because of my past experiences
um I I where I am now I don't want to be
with someone that's on a camera
um I feel like
especially because I have a child and
where I want to be in life I don't want
someone that's going to come up uh maybe
a few years ago it was fine but where I
am now I want you to be at least a
certain level and a certain amount of
money consistently I don't want to have
to raise your support you consistently
how much money is it how much money do
you know what it doesn't have to be a
large amount of money because I'm not
like what's the word high maintenance or
let me Google hold on yeah it just
average average salary UK
okay you want everything I feel like
someone just be able to live maintain be
able to go out on events and do things
it doesn't have to be crazy but as long
as you're London 41 000 pounds if he
earns that yeah that's the average says
the average yearly wage for full-time
workers in London in 2022 according to
status
yeah I think that would be fine for me I
don't you don't have to be a millionaire
or billionaire no way you just have to
be able to support yourself so that we
can rise together I don't want someone
that's down and then I have to pull you
up because I've got a child I don't have
time to be pulling up everyone then
there's rebuttal is what are you
bringing to the table well my bringing
to the table
I'm bringing myself
I can do yeah but yeah I bring a lot to
the table why do you hate the question I
hate that question but it's like if
you're interviewing for a job you have
to show them your resume yeah experience
yeah yeah of course but I feel like when
men ask that question
I feel like we should be asking you what
are you bringing to the table because
I've had dinner you want bags you know
what's nice yeah but you're forgetting a
woman is going to first of all she's
going to make your house
she is going to raise your kids most
modern women can make a house a home do
those modern women have recipes from
scratch no no not modern women
they're tick tock not necessarily
not necessarily but what I mean is she
is going to make your house feel like a
home she is going to be there for you
specifically
well you would you would do duties
around the house but not every woman
does that now it's a certain type of
woman you're talking about so like what
I mean personally that a hooker a cook
and a cleaner can't do but she's gonna
be providing you with support
emotionally but I just thought like when
men hear this it's like it's like we're
saying nothing oh okay it's like not
like it's not specific as I can do this
I have the skill this this and this my
mama can do that do you know what it is
obviously there's a lot of my sexuality
and my role is basically that the
Melrose so that's why I'm just asking
these little ones and twos to throw you
off but also to get a better
understanding but I don't really hearing
it's not matching up to the 41. I don't
forget why everything's always centered
around finances I understand you need
money to survive but I don't understand
where women have the high expectations
of expecting a man to have so much money
to get with him like how can I thought
like if you love someone it's based on
love like not just based on what you can
pick like it's like you can take all
these boxes but where's the love in that
um don't get it one thing I realized
from being in a relationship love is not
enough love is not so you can love life
it's great to be in love but it's not
it's everything peace and love is life I
okay we can say that a man wants peace
when you think about it and he wants
love you can be in love with someone
love them dearly but when the bills come
is that love gonna pay you need to lower
your maintenance then you've got your
high expectations you should be
providing for yourself and you can't
expect the man to do that no but yeah
for example okay you live together
there's certain things that a woman May
pay and there's certain things that a
man May pay okay you both work love is
not going to pay those bills love is not
going to keep you woman what you enjoy
when you survive the life of a household
together you survive that's how it works
I mean you become accustomed to the
wealth that you make in your household I
get that but that's that's not the way I
would want to live my life yeah to be
able to enjoy I want to be in love and
be able to say okay so if your man makes
more more than you why should why is he
expected to make more and you make less
and you both live the same it doesn't
have to make more he just said he has to
make more didn't you no no I didn't say
he has to make more I said if I made
more I wouldn't be able to submit to him
he's going to make so he has to make
more we could make the same amount we'd
be happy with the same amount yeah I'd
be happy with the same amount but I find
I'll know if he makes
less than me it would be harder for me
to submit because I just I just that's
how I see it I can't even put a nail on
it but I know if a man-made left you
think Society has a role to play in that
that finances got taken 100 I'm probably
rather than your love life yeah part of
me it's taken do you think Society has
taken a toll on how you love someone
because it's supposed to be love yeah um
no I think it's just the way I see love
I feel like love is not enough maybe
love is based on material then basically
no what I think love is is you can love
someone but maybe uh what can I say so
say you was with a man and he was rich
and then he went broke would you stay
with him 100 because what's the
difference
the difference is because you've gone
broke I didn't meet you bro why can't
you help somebody get ripped if you can
help them stay bro yeah because it's a
mentality thing if it could get rich in
the first place then I know in my heart
he can get rich again I believe that I
believe a good man I know it is
personally I get what you're trying to
say a good person can see potential in
somebody from nothing the problem is if
I speak for my personal experiences I am
always the one seeing potential in
people and always maybe there's
something that you should look within
yourself that might need fixing when
choosing a partner then maybe it's not
the man maybe you know what it is maybe
it is but that's why I've made a
decision to say I'm not looking I'm not
going to go with somebody that is I'm
not going to look at anyone's potential
anymore because we can see potential for
days it doesn't mean that they're going
to reach that so what I've learned is I
now want to be with someone or get to
date someone that is at a certain stage
that I can say okay you're not you're
pulling up stage I don't have to pull
you up I think that's very unfair on men
well maybe that is but that's my opinion
that's where I am now I've given people
chances pull them up you want a high
value man I wouldn't say high value but
someone that is that I value yeah
because it's a high value but you've got
a child as well yeah if we're going to
use that term it's 10K a month that's
that's high value
well I wouldn't say high value I just
want someone that is able to pay their
bills feed themselves okay so what if a
guy ticked all them boxes and
emotionally you don't feel nothing but
besides that it's absolutely perfect
would you say I don't like him like
there's no emotional connection there's
no love there you said love isn't what
you used to be so no I said love isn't
enough so I can love someone but
everything else has you have to be
respectful you have to have to say take
all them boxes yeah but you love them a
little bit
um
love is important he tips with them
boxes what I think that question was
that if if a man ticked all the boxes
yeah and you loved him a little bit is
that good enough
no okay no it's not do you I agree with
you sorry do you think there's a minimum
that like a guy has to have a job right
okay yeah yeah I mean I think I think
it's dishonest when we say It's All
About Love because I think at some point
if a guy's unemployed for five years
you're probably gonna leave I think it's
about the mentality of a person so like
if somebody's broke if I say I met
someone and he's broke but he's got the
right mentality to conquer the world and
by all means I can support him and I can
help him I'm happy to do that no I I
agree with you it's about mentality but
I just think when we're asking these
questions it's like what what is the
minimum
I don't have a moment if I if I like
somebody and I believe in them then they
got my support but how long how long are
you believing in them until they like as
long as I think it's difficult say I
have money and the man doesn't have any
money if he can respect my values and
like believe that I'm putting him in
positions to help him then
if he's getting off every day at six in
the morning and he's trying and trying
you can't fault somebody like that
because we're all from difference but
for how long and there's no don't talk
about deals but I'm just I think I've
got a whole different perspective of
life because of myself my lifestyle and
how I've been brought up like what's
different about your lifestyle
everything I've hit my life upbringing
experience is completely different to a
lot of people okay so I don't really
want to dig too deep on him even being
honest but I just do believe that my
circumstances are quite unique
I just don't think money is everything
so what would it take for you not to
believe in him anymore for you to say
okay call my first like perspective of
this man was wrong and he's actually a
like not a bum sorry Bob if he's
behaving like a bum then obviously
that's a huge red red flag that he
doesn't really want to change his life
he's quite happy being mediocre so yeah
so that's when you'll leave when you
realize his true mentality yeah but I
haven't ever encountered a situation
like that too
say I'm going like okay what were you
gonna say you had something to say
earlier yeah I just um agree with you
sorry I forgot you're lucky
um I agree with you and I feel like what
you were trying to say was
yes your love is you love someone but
it's as a woman it's
conditional and I'm gonna be honest as a
woman like my love is conditional yes I
can love you and yes I can have these
amazing beautiful memories with you but
if you are not bringing those qualities
that I want and you are not going to
contribute to the life that I want for
myself then that love is not enough for
me it's not enough for me and if I'm
honest with you I'm not really looking
to be with someone and do the whole
struggle of things yeah I'll be honest
I'm not I'll agree yes if you have
dreams but it's not my job to sit here
and motivate you and be holding your
hand while you're doing it I'm not
looking for a project I'm looking for
someone who is established because I
feel like as a high value woman I am
allowed to seek a high value man
especially because I know what I bring
to the table so I want someone to match
that as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible